my god so many women running for president yeah I think it's very great hopes II gather Kirsten Gillibrand come on Harris Amy Klobuchar right Elizabeth Warren yeah it's a lot of women running for president right that's five five female Democrats running for president very cool ladies and gentlemen to put that in perspective there are three female Republicans total in the United States and the entire that's three they're not even in politics oh really oh yeah I just voted that way yeah senator Kamala Harris is being criticized for not being black enough yes which frankly is the same criticism I've had to endure my entire career boy eat even while you were fronting Earth Wind & Fire I know you'd think I caught a lot of flack for that you know Amy Klobuchar has been described as president Trump's worst nightmare yes Trump heard this and he said actually my worst nightmare is a Mexican guy forcing me to eat a salad that's my it was not enough fat